compétent oui effectivement c'est cette
division qui nous ça revient sur
résultats
parce que moi j'avais voulu apporter sur
la commune
amusement plus populaire plus proche de
la population
les habitants de france entière on
entend dire que les gens souhaitent de
politique notre mort c'est ce que j'ai
voulu faire et je constate qu'à voir une
pause est longue et encore pas prêt pour
ça j'ai subi six ans de violence
perpétuelle aujourd'hui par ma foi cette
violence elle a fait son chemin je n'ai
jamais répondu tout à l'heure même je me
suis fait siffler au moment des
résultats si c'est une saison qui
s'annonce six ans alençon dans cette
optique là je trouve que la démocratie a
beaucoup perdu ce soir
m
il
alors j'ai du mal à faire voter des
budgets évidemment puisque mais j'aurais
été s'étaient divisés donc monsieur sico
et quelqu'un qui est très fort au niveau
du discours qui l'a entraîné dans son
sillage des personnes de mon groupe qui
ont écouté ses propos maintenant est-ce
que c'est avec des paroles pour doit
diriger une commune où est ce que c'est
avec de la sensibilité si vous reprenez
le débat que nous avons eu a dit jean
mus aussi qu à aucun moment n'a évoqué
ni varennes-vauzelles ni les bohémiens
s'intéresse-t-il à sa fille il était
parti sur de la politique japon voilà je
pense que vous avez compris dans quelle
ambiance on est à varennes-vauzelles a
été un rassemblement on me dit un peu de
dignité je ne sais pas qui manque de
dignité en ce moment mais c'est pas
grave je suis battu mais je serai
toujours pas tendres et je reviendrai et
je vais faire mon travail d'opposant je
ne baisserai pas les bras je ne
laisserai pas tomber je suis là pour les
blues
je suis là pour la ville de bruxelles